the trash is right right down the middle  and cause a strike to swing swing  think about it prey  from the forty fields rolls out and  looks to throw and they fooled them and  visited [ __ ] wide-open mix of all  [Music]  those sicko touchdown happens is nobody  picks up benjamin victor after he has  shows that block the other defensive  backs and man-to-man and now it's victor  who SH and if the snap occurs just after  just as that clock hits zero all game  and then the linebacker has a chance to  stop the play bounces off the tackle and  then yards after contact make it a long  run for a touchdown one missed tackle  the secondary is up playing really tight  and he's gone probably won't need him  but they do have all three timeouts  [Applause]  caging handler in the slot here blitz  coming  flipper Maximo  [Applause]  [Music]